bailey it's so good to see you kevin
it's nice to meet you over zoom
i loved this movie i thought it was such
a nice
adorable uplifting watch during
quarantine it kind of reminded me of
camp rock meets
saved did you guys ever see saved no but
that's on that's on the list now i like
that
it's with mandy moore and it's so much
fun and i like that there's a religious
element to this his will hawkins file
social services put everything in there
you didn't tell me this was church camp
what do you guys hope viewers
feel as they watch this movie i hope
viewers feel
a sense of purpose and belonging uh and
you know with the whole faith aspect i
hope that they can
find these answers for themselves i
think this movie is a great catalyst to
ask some questions
and i hope that they do ask those
questions and
whatever the journey is i would pray
that it's a fruitful one
i i love i love the idea that especially
now more than ever we're all looking to
kind of find some hope and some love and
some light um
so wherever you are in your life i would
i would hope that there's something to
kind of feed your soul uh while you
watch it but um
but the hope is that no matter where you
are no matter who you are
you can see yourself in this movie in
some way
i love these interviews because they're
just so uplifting just like this movie
and it makes my morning
[Music]
nice to meet you what's her story did
you guys do
all your own singing in this
we both yeah wow you know we actually
had a
vocal booth and a music studio on the
campgrounds
in tennessee kevin does music and he's
amazing at it uh
music i've always wanted to do since i
was a little girl and
so it was really exciting to get to
combine you know
the the world of singing and dancing and
then co-producing with like the actings
to put all of my little babies in a box
was like the most
nerve-wracking but exciting thing so
that's us
unless you don't think i sound good then
it's not me
is this singing too much i couldn't
decide no nothing no that's what got me
no you guys sounded so good
bailey you are a co-producer on this so
what was it like for you to put that
producing hat on it was a joy i deeply
care and love this movie
so so much and so it was it was a lot of
conversations for those four weeks of
going through scenes and and talking
about the moments we found our home with
netflix you know three months cutting
the trailers talking with the team
being on all of those calls so it's a
lot that people don't get to see
that really fuels my heart and um and i
feel very very connected in all the ways
this movie so great
as a co-producer i'm hoping you have an
answer to this and kevin you too
but at the end we obviously see that
uh avery and will share a kiss they talk
about
camp next year what are the chances we
get
a sequel
we told you that would be crazy wouldn't
it uh
no i mean fingers crossed i feel like uh
i feel like we would love to go back to
camp and i think it's you know
let the viewers speak but we love
netflix and we've got ideas
i'm ready to go trust me i'm ready i've
gone hit the ground running let's do it
i would love to go back to camp with
these guys
any day uh i mean it was it was
an experience of a lifetime and we'd
love to do it again um me and gibral
were just talking about
let's go to camp in paris or you know
take it to literally in space
the possibilities are endless would you
guys do camp somewhere
else cat mention maybe camp in paris
camp in paris i'm like camping for a
borah
camp in london let's go
i think it would be fun to see like to
see where they all are
and i i'm even like what would happen if
will become like became a camp counselor
like maybe it's not their week off in
camp maybe it's when they're running the
camp
what does that look like i'm just just
balancing ideas right now we keep it in
though in case it happens
there is a reason why it's the 24th
summer at camp a week away and not the
25th
so if that's any indication ah gotta go
big for that 25th year right
my kids have you completely lost your
mind my pride and joy
geeky d and mark hi you guys
bailey it's been i can't believe this 10
years
since just go with it came out did you
know that right
like wow so i guess what do you remember
most about working with jen and adam on
that movie
and do you stay in touch with them
goodness i i remember so much i
am actually adam has been brought up in
a lot of the conversations uh
with the with some of the netflix team
because i was working with his trailer
company and cutting the trailer for this
with everyone
i think the thing with adam like one of
the things that he did was it was
mother's day
uh when we were filming and my mom was
just with me and obviously was missing
all of my siblings
uh so we literally flew everybody out to
surprise my mom for valentine or for
mother's day
and uh and we all just like got to be
together and she cried and
i think that's just him in a nutshell
he's got the same crew that he's always
had
he is the most lovely to his family um
and to his people around and then you
know i still call jen mama jen
uh because she does feel like that to me
um and there there wasn't a moment where
i didn't just feel you know such warmth
and i think
i learned so much from her without even
realizing that i was that as
i'm growing older trying to navigate
this world
uh it all makes a lot of sense and she's
beautiful inside now and
always lovely when i got to see her
again so i'm grateful i love that
kevin for you i will say so we were
watching this movie yesterday
and my fiance walked in and was like is
that zac efron
yeah no really everybody thinks it kevin
right everyone does think it so i'm
wondering if that's endearing to you
or exciting to you oh yeah i mean
of course he's a he's a good looking guy
i mean i'd rather be
zac efron than someone else you know
completely not looking good looking dude
but uh
no it's very flattering and uh i know
that
zach is very talented i've seen some of
his works so
to be able to be compared to that i mean
it's very flattering yeah i am getting
wrapped so my last question bailey is
for you
you and i think your boyfriend both
turned 21
during quarters we did it was wild
how did you celebrate and do you feel
good for being 21.
you know a lot of uh a lot of a lot of
the big anniversaries all those things
have happened over face time because
obviously everything is you know
pandemic
um i did actually have to go out to the
uk so i had to go for work and
i was able to to see him in a
quarantined bubble
uh so we were we were grateful to have
that but uh no it was a whole lot of
water
and we're both not drinkers i'll be
honest nothing cool there but
uh but yeah it was it was chill actually
i got like a i amazon to myself a 21st
birthday stash
so there was that and kate i did have
cake delivered i was i was good on that
i promise i didn't disappoint didn't you
yeah what is 21 without cake right
yeah his cake was a little dodgy poor
guy he did not order from the right
place he wasn't falling apart when we
got it
it's a good story to laugh about